welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for Craven the latest in Sony
Spider-Man villain series following the
Venom films and morbius this one
starring Aaron Taylor-Johnson as Craven
the hunter let's break down this trailer
shot by shot for everything he missed
everything you need to know about Craven
before this movie drops on October 6th
and yeah we're looking at the red band
trailer because we're dirty little jerks
also Marvel's a secret invasion is
coming to Disney plus June 21st my
Easter egg breakdown is coming to the
new Rockstar's main channel that day
around 3 P.M Eastern and there are a ton
of details and conspiracy theories and
pepe Silvio walls so you gotta tune in
you're gonna love our Nelson's also our
after show inside Marvel is coming back
to Wednesday mornings and they're gonna
be live in person and it will transition
to being a break room Channel exclusive
so be sure to subscribe to the break
room as well as subscribe to the Deep
dive Channel and to this channel for all
kinds of great content all right let's
get started with this trailer breakdown
[Applause]
all right we're in London and Craven AKA
Sergey cravenov projects his senses
through the streets giving us a sense of
Craven's animalistic instincts as his
Center his perception Glides through he
actually could be linking his Mind's Eye
with that of a bird since connecting
with animals this way is part of his
power set in this movie from Craven's
first appearance in The Amazing
Spider-Man number 15 in 1964. he has had
enhanced agility and speed and hunting
prowess from a magical herbal potion
that he drinks he was born to a Russian
Aristocrat from the days of the 1917
Revolution and he was motivated by Pride
to fulfill a sense of lost nobility but
in this movie they've definitely changed
Craven because you know Russell Crowe
wasn't alive during the 1917 Revolution
and now Sergey is more of an animal
rights activist trying to make up for an
upbringing in a family of big game
Hunters led by his father Nikolai
cravenov played by Russell Crowe let's
move on to the next part of the trailer
my son never show Mercy
they are playing
okay we see Craven sprinting Barefoot
through London looking like her man
Steve Rogers in the first Captain
America film because these guys are
faster without shoes shoes slow him down
and with shoes how would he a monkey
latch onto that car God gave us toes for
gripping folks actually in set photos
showing Aaron Taylor Johnson they gave
him some slip-on Hobbit style feet okay
on to the next clip
we
are predators who is your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind so yes Russell
Crowe Playing sergey's Father Nikolai
cravenov the third time he's played a
superhero Papa after jorel and Zeus he
baptizes his son with a cross of blood
on his forehead the blood of the animal
they just killed foreshadowing the
importance of these animals blood to
Craven's origin now if you grew up
Christian like I did you know crosses
like this is what they put in your
forehead and Ash on Ash Wednesday when
you get confirmed it's oil it's an
important religious Sacrament and I
think it gives us a glimpse into this
family's weird philosophy when it comes
to hunting animals then in his car
beside young Sergey is his brother
Dimitri aka the chameleon the adult
version of whom is going to be played by
Fred hetzinger who is the kid from White
Lotus season one and the comic scenes 2
are half Brothers but in this movie it
seems to indicate that they have the
same father and the same mother Nikolai
says that she was weak sick in the mind
avenging her could be the deeper
motivator in sergey's Warpath moving on
you'll know my business yes
power is about strength all right we see
an opulent Castle tucked in the side of
a mountain it kind of looks like the
pretty drama Castle it's Slovenia
there's a room with a stuffed Fox on the
bar on the wall that Nikolai pushes
Sergey against is a stuffed lion head I
might be wrong but all this seems like
it might be taking place in a heightened
underworld with just different rules
when it comes to assassins like this
kind of like John Wick which might help
some of the ultra violence we can expect
from this film next clip you will give
our enemies an opening
[Applause]
Sergey and Dimitri joined Nikolai on a
lion hunt and the lion pounces actually
at one point you can see the lion with
both Paws wrapped around Sergey bite in
his head like a burrito now lions are
typically nocturnal Predators they only
rarely hunt during the day like in
situations where water in their
territories is attracting prey animals
they can eat but the overwhelming
majority of attacks from Lions happen at
night time so this is some special
circumstance and a very special lion
he's noticed it's bulk and it's length
it's definitely larger than the average
lion this thing is freakishly jacked and
lumpy kind of like Aaron Taylor Johnson
is in this movie let's move on
like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self as poor
Sergey lies wounded a figure stands over
into the background could be Calypso
which is his love interest in this movie
played by Ariana Dubose you know her
she's the one who said that Angela
Bassett did the thing although maybe the
person background here is just someone
else in their hunting party now in the
shot of Nikolai saying leave him the
visual itself is actually taken from an
earlier moment because we see Sergey
standing behind him looking healthy and
fine but the guy with glasses here is
Alexi sistovich played by Alessandro
navola who in this movie will turn into
a version of the Rhino we'll see him at
the end of the trailer but then crazy
happens a drop of lion blood falls
into sergey's wound and we see some red
blood cell imagery again to Sam Remy's
opening spider DNA imagery in the 2000
Spider-Man films we hear the voice of
calypso over this Calypso is a voodoo
priestess in the comics who gives Sergey
the potion that enhances his physical
strength into that of a jungle cat but
here it looks like his powers are going
to come from this transfusion process
blood from maybe a genetically
engineered lion or a mystical mutant
lion mixing in with sergey's blood yes
it's kind of like Catwoman and yes it
makes no sense we see a Tarot Death card
with a skeleton on Horseback carrying a
scythe may be part of a ritual that
Calypso could do for him but now when
the camera pulls back out of his eye it
glows yellow and the people becomes
elongated like that of a cat these cat
eyes glow yellow in the dark like a cat
like the night man
ahead of Sergey stepping at the Shadows
let's move on tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off okay swissy
sergeying using his connection with the
animals to fight these poachers and big
game hunters and other criminal
organizations that profit from this kind
of thing so yes he's a hunter but an
anti-hero Hunter not yet a Spider-Man
villain despite these guys connection to
Spider-Man being really what makes them
interesting but you know don't tell Sony
that they're gonna keep trying to do
this this video is sponsored by Helix
sleep no matter what kind of sleeper you
are Helix is a mattress for you their
sleep quiz makes it easy to find the
perfect match I wanted a medium bird
mattress with lumbar support that sleeps
cool so I got matched with the dusk Luxe
Helix mattress I've had my Helix
mattress for well over a year now I love
it I fall asleep faster I sleep deeper
and I find it easier to share a bed with
my partner than ever before Helix
delivers right to your door with free
shipping in the U.S the mattress comes
rolled up in a box and it's super easy
to set up yourself ain't no way this is
about to be a whole mattress right now
ain't no way look at this it's all
curled up and if you're nervous to buy
something that you haven't test driven
Helix has a 100 night sleep trial so
you'll have more than three months to
make sure that you love it Helix
mattresses also have a 10-year warranty
and they offer financing options and
flexible payment plans so great night's
sleep is never far away I love my Helix
mattress I think you would too so click
the link below or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars to get 20 off your Helix
mattress plus two free pillows we see
Sergey running across a tundra in a
blizzard pursued by guys and snowmobiles
and then he uses his connection with
Wolves to kill them a close-up of a
night blinking into a yellow bird eye as
it spies on these poachers having killed
some livestock now while in the comics
Craven is known to tame animals and to
work with animals sometimes it's only
been theorized that in some cases he
might have a psychic link with them but
no this movie is making him a full-on
psychically linked worg really
Christopher Abbott in this movie is
playing the Foreigner who is a
Spider-Man villain an assassin capable
of putting someone in a 10 second
hypnotic trance by making eye contact
with them I wonder if he'll be able to
do that by looking at the animal craving
his controlling and be able to put him
in a trance wherever he actually is on
to the next clip the six of us only one
of you there's six of you now
[Music]
okay Craven confronts the poachers and
some old Soviet trucks he wears a
necklace with a lion tooth and the
comics is a saber-toothed tiger Fang
that he wears around his neck here it
might be a token from The Lion who
attacked him and then our man goes to
work stabbing them in the next with like
a horn and then swinging the cap of the
truck to stab the driver and then bites
off the nose of the other guy and spits
it at us yeah kind of like Danny DeVito
and Batman Returns Craven had already
stabbed him in the neck the guy was
already bleeding out why do you have to
give him a closed casket Jesus was the
livestock they were poaching your best
friend's Craven because I think even the
animal's ghost would be like stop stop
he's already dead
he's already dead Jesus let's move on
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
so Craven tries to justify his violence
Calypso suggesting that all of his
targets are really part of his father's
crime organization I mean okay but you
could just shoot them we do see two guys
get shot through the head with one
bullet but then he claps a bear trap on
a dude's head he had to walk around with
a spring-loaded bear trap ready to go
without triggering it and then at the
right moment clamped it on his head so
just a reminder the scorecard here folks
our hero in this movie is biting off
noses and clapping bear traps on heads I
mean look maybe he's trying to avenge
his mom or maybe we're just not meant to
like this character because even
everyone in this trailer is like dude
why are you doing this you were exactly
like our father just another man hunting
for a trophy
the murderers
isn't that what he taught us yeah
Dimitri's calling his brother a
hypocrite a man hunting for trophies
just like their father now chameleon was
technically Spider-Man's first official
villain in the comics appeared in 1963's
Amazing Spider-Man man number one he's
known for being able to take anyone's
identity but in this trailer we don't
really see him do anything chameleony
yet Sergey jumps on a desk stabs the
dude in the neck with some kind of Tusk
now I'm wondering if the weapon that he
uses to kill each person is either part
of the animal they killed or the type of
weapon that they were going to use to
kill it like it could be a kind of
poetic justice to give the animal the
final say but again I think the animal
would just be like just let me live and
protect my young and have access to
water please next clip
you don't get to do that to me anymore
to tagline
where's Mr tagline oh you're standing in
him
spiders
of course there are spiders in this Sony
also randomly threw a spider in the
Venom Let There Be Carnage trailer that
ended up not meaning anything but hey
look now there are several spiders
because there's a live-action spider
verse on the horizon but there could be
more to this because Craven considers
the Spider-Man the one Beast that he's
always long to hunt the one to always
slip through his fingers but here it's
interesting how he looks frightened in
the comics Craven kind of becomes
obsessed with images of a spider
infested Asylum because his mother was
locked away and won so this might be the
one Beast he's afraid of the one he
can't psychically connect with as
spiders of their own psychic link that
you gotta be a spider person to connect
with maybe planting some seeds here for
Craven's eventual hatred of Spider-Man
coming from an animal he can never
connect with and one associated with his
mother's suffering a quick shot of
Craven lifting the lion main vest from
the box his iconic look from the comics
which is shortly after seen wearing in a
cave with a flaming spear his necklace
here now has three teeth on it so maybe
after he's killed the people who left
him to die including also his father and
Rhino could this be the ending of the
movie but here we see that six of us
versus one of you guy from earlier he
finds Craven in the office of a Mr
tagline on the wall we see a rhino head
a Ram's Head a silver cow head there's
an alligator head on the left shelf bird
statues a huge ivory tusk in the window
so yeah Mr taglan a dirtbag now you know
Craven's going Captain Planet all over
his ass but he takes out this guy with
the biggest crossbow I've ever seen and
then he crosses out the name from the
book something Obe Levine and beside it
rooster now I'm wondering if this could
be from a post-credits scene and that
when we see this list in the movie there
will be other names on it names like
Michael morbius Adrian tombs Eddie Brock
let's move on you're a goddamn lunatic
oh you just figured that out now
okay and this shot Craven has some scars
on his right arm in the process of
healing and then a hallway fight as he
pounces on the walls I'd say like a lion
but I don't think Lions could even get
three gallops around the side of a
corner of a hallway it's kind of hard to
tell what's going on because it looks
like they shot this through gutter water
okay onto the last clip there is an
animal in each one of us don't you want
to know why they call me the rhino
okay
the trailer ends with Alexi revealing
himself as the Rhino but not the kind of
rhino that we've seen before this guy
detaches a tube that might give him the
serum that turns into a rhino or a baits
it we're not really sure but in the
comics Alexi sistovich received gamma
radiation that enhanced his size and
strength and then he wore a polymer suit
over it that gave him the appearance of
a rhino but in 2014's The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 Paul Giamatti played a
version of the Rhino who wore a mech
suit that he stole look folks I'm
excited to see Aaron Taylor Johnson as
Craven but from this trailer he looks
like a psychopath savaging people to an
extent no natural animal in the wild
would bother to do and I'm just not
really rooting for him at the moment but
again maybe that's not the point let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
subscribe to new rockstars and the Deep
dive and the break room and support us
by grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at EA
Vos follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you